he is dominating jeopardy right now
James Holzhauer and he's a professional
sports gambler he's a native of
Naperville Illinois but he has been he's
been killing it I think four of the top
five money scores of all time have been
turned in by James the jeopardy champion
contestant and I believe that he's won
11 consecutive games he joins us now
James good morning how you feeling hi
Dan feeling great what is your
background
educational background oh you know I
went to the University of Illinois but I
barely attended class so I'd like to say
my real major was online poker ice to
play online poker and I ran a strategy
website and that was how I initially got
my sports betting bankroll how did you
become an expert at trivia oh you know I
kind of made a concerted effort I
stepped away from trivia when I met my
wife try dude I'm sorry I just I stepped
away from sports betting for a few years
when I met my wife tried to start a
family and kind of became a pet project
of mine I would always wanted to go on
Jeopardy since I was a kid but I decided
to really step it up take it seriously
during that time how do you prepare no I
I've said in the media several times I
if I don't know anything about a subject
I go to the library and I check out like
the most basic level children's book I
can find on the subject so with lots of
pictures easy to read you know get
through the basics of it and really get
to interested you know that's the whole
point of the children's library is to
get you interested in stuff you never
would have thought about before what's
your best category ooh
probably something like football really
well you know gamble on football I do
yeah there was a question on the when
they move the extra point kick back and
I couldn't think of it on Ted
at the time on stage so maybe football
isn't the best but are you what kind of
GAMP sports gambler are you how
successful I mean you know I started out
betting baseball that I branched out
into football hockey basketball now
basically wherever the money is you know
they've gotten a lot better at setting
odds and they were when I started 13
years ago you also have a different
strategy here that you go you go down
low you go for the big big-ticket items
surely it that's been your philosophy
throughout this run yeah you know I
don't think it's a too complicated of a
strategy I want to have much of money
when the daily devil comes up I want it
that big when the daily doubles there
you obviously can't do that unless you
have a stack of chips already do you try
to intimidate your opponents oh goodness
no I mean if they're intimidated at the
side-effect that's fine but no I'm not
trying to play dirty or anything it's
just what I feel is the best strategy
for the game you want a piece of Ken
Jennings in what arena
well no but just you you against him so
it's head-to-head on Jeopardy just you
against him yeah I mean I Jeopardy's a
three-player game I expect that a third
player would be invited but I would love
to have the chance to have a
head-to-head deathmatch with them and
you had a perfect game they uh yeah
there's an offshore sight actually that
started taking bets on a potential
matchup between me and him and they made
me the favorite so are you allowed to
bet on yourself I would think that would
be a problem
afflictive interest I haven't tried no
if you bet on yourself to win and in an
offshore like boxers can do this yeah I
guess I don't know it I don't think it
would be worth trying they probably got
like a fifty dollar limit on this or
something the single toughest question
where you could have lost do you
remember you know I don't know that
there's been a that close of a shave I
mean there's been times when I was lucky
enough to hit the Daily Double in front
of my opponent and I probably would've
lost that game you know when you know
there was one question I asked which
Eastern women's college used to be known
as Sadie Lou and I was lucky because my
wife and I had talked about Sadie its
potential name for our daughter when she
was born and so I knew Sadie was a
diminutive massara
so Sadie Louisville Sarah Lawrence and I
would have definitely lost in my second
game so I had not known that what would
be your dream sports category ooh good
questions maybe like a match
baseball hall-of-famer to his exact home
run total we have one my guys did sports
jeopardy and and there was the final
sports jeopardy I love that show
bring it back yeah but I can I can't put
you on there you'll dominate ok here
here's the hint Pauly do you have the
answer
yeah the hint was Yankee Stadium in
Monument Park at Yankee Stadium there's
a plaque that reads in belated
recognition of one of baseball's
greatest achievements ever oh yeah Josh
Gibson right hitting the ball out no oh
no it's Roger Maris who is Roger Maris
I'm sorry James but we have some nice
parting gifts for you
yes McLovin what can we give him the
other one who is the all-time leading
3-point percentage in NBA history and
there was a hint about he happens what
was a hint and remember he has the same
first name as his star player no no no
no no no no he's screwed it up there
yeah well do you know the all-time
leading 3-point shooter percentage
command percentage up off the top of my
head no I don't Steve Kerr yes Steve
Kerr is correct yeah welcome and he's
done it again and James host hours done
it again how famous have you become oh
there's a funny story I had from last
week I was out of aigis and someone came
up to me and said hey last game was
painful to watch got to play better
tonight I said okay I'll do my best I
notice that I'm wearing a nice Jersey
she's wearing a nice Church and she
probably wasn't talking about Jeopardy
but I got noticed a few times lots of
old people seem to watch jeopardy based
on who's coming up and saying hi wait
wait who did she think you were on Las
Vegas night like a hockey player yeah I
think she was just saying like hey
Congrats it's been great great run and
James we appreciate your time
all right James Holzhauer he's the
jeopardy champion contestant there he's
won 11 in a row so far and they taped
these so I don't know how many he ends
up winning in a row but I think for the
top
five scores of all time for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app